this is the police helicopter arriving
by Lake annasie there this is very close
to the park where there's a tax took
place about which we know nothing
currently of the motivations we know
that the attacker was not known
to Security Services but we can see
there as we'll be discussing
now with our International correspondent
John Sparks John it appears to have been
a very rapid response from police rapid
and comprehensive
yes it does look that way doesn't it
from the pictures the Emergency Services
armed police also in attendance we heard
via Twitter from the French interior
Minister he said that the individual was
arrested thanks to very rapid
intervention of the police so they have
intervened
quickly at what we also know is that the
the numbers of injured have been revised
downward
when this incident was first reported we
understood that four children had been
injured and two adults We Now understand
that two children have suffered very
severe injuries and those children it
has been reported are three years old
both of those children and one adult has
also suffered from very severe injuries
the French President Emil macro he has
tweeted he said an absolutely cowardly
attack this morning in a park in anisee
children and an adult are between life
and death the nation is in shock our
thoughts are with them their families
and the emergency services so a very
disturbing attack and
anisee
the city medieval city it's beautiful it
sits at the head of Lake Anna sea this
is the beginning of the summer season
for them it would be busy though it's a
medieval town be packed with squares and
Lanes tourists and and residents as well
and these pictures here we can see are
from Parkland which surround the head of
Lake annasie open space playgrounds
places to to relax to run to exercise as
well and it's really not the sort of
thing that anybody using that place
would expect
do we know about the attacker so we've
had a a few details now that are being
reported uh the attacker a Syrian
National we understand with legal
Refugee status in France that from a
police Source we are also hearing that
the attacker was not known to security
agencies again that a source reporting
that close to the invest investigation
so that the motivations
of this person are unclear we simply do
not know at this stage